120 тисяч строковиків саме стільки мають
призвати до армії Росії в рамках
осіннього призову у Міноборони РФ
наголосили що призовників на війну в
Україну відправляти не будуть але закону
який забороняється робити у Росії немає
у Росії немає жодного нормативного
документа який забороняє відправлення
строковиків у зону бойових дій єдине
обмеження це в положенні про проходження
військової служби затвердженої указом
Президента те що строковики можуть бути
направлені до зони бойових дій лише
через чотири місяці після їхнього
призову на військову службу та утримання
первинної військово-облікової
спеціальності
спеціальність
теоретичного строковиків можуть
відправити в Україну вже на початку
весни кажуть експерти І хоча поки що
масово призовників на фронт ще не
перекидали про окремі такі випадки стало
відомо що на самому початку війни але
частіше у російській армії практикують
інше на передову відправляють тих хто
щойно відслужив строкову
це поширена Практика коли строковиків
змушують або пропонують підписувати
контракт Я буквально вчора розмовляв із
строковиком який недавно демобілізувався
запитував його вас змушували підписувати
контракт Ні не змушували але пропонували
така робота йде скрізь з різним ступенем
тиску
десь дійсно примусово робиться через
силу погрозами а десь чисто формально
хочеш не хочеш Ну і не треба
і Спочатку ми осіннього призову збіглося
і оголошення про закінчення
мобілізаційних заходів у Росії процес
спочатку повідомили у Міноборони Росії а
згодом підтвердив прес-секретар Путіна
Дмитро пісков при цьому указ про
закінчення мобілізації Путін не підписав
правозахисники вважаються головним
свідченням того що її не закінчено
надо смотреть на потрібно дивитися на ті
нормативні документи які є й
опубліковані і настав час не довіряти
навіть голослівним твердження президента
і міністра оборони тому що 21 вересня
опубліковано Указ президента про
мобілізацію і все цім указом її
оголошено і де-юре вона продовжується
формально осінній призов та мобілізації
можуть відбуватися паралельно
розповідають експерти для цього не мають
юридичних перешкод щоправда є проблеми
технічного характеру цьому нічого не
заважає інша справа що навряд чи
військкомати впораються одночасно з
потоками призовників і мобілізованих
Наприклад щоб призвати у військкоматі в
якомусь регіоні три тисячі осіб на
строкову службу потрібно прогнати через
структури Міноборони через військові
комісаріати втричі більше людей тому що
там велика кількість тих хто навчається
і хто не придатний за станом здоров'я
кому потрібно перевіряти ще раз стан
здоров'я
у кремні тим часом повідомили що жодного
указу для завершення мобілізації не
потрібно водночас російські депутати
розробили законопроєкт який передбачає
кримінальне покарання для ухилянтів до 5
років позбавлення волі тим часом
мобілізація яка призвела до масового
виїзду з РФ працездатних росіян уже
негативно відбивається на російській
економіці російський ринок труда
знаходиться
в особливо цікавому становищі в якому
він не знаходився ніколи Тому що з
одного боку є пряме відрахування з
трудової сили мобілізованих а з іншого
боку є також пряме відрахування з
трудової сили тих що виїхали і це перш
за все креативний клас освічені люди які
рухають продуктивність рухають галузі
які спритні які заповзятливі активні та
молодісти которые предприничивые которые
активные и которые молодые при цьому
російський ринок праці страждає не лише
через масовий від'їзд співробітників
іт-сфери та кре галузей серйозним шоком
для нього ставити дефіцит
малокваліфікованих кадрів ці роботи
традиційно виконували чоловіки збідніших
верст населення які нині воюють проти
України при цьому експерти визнають що
нині ще надто мало даних для проведення
адекватного аналізу наслідки мобілізації
раніше кварталу ви не дізнаєтеся жодних
цифр навіть більш-менш приблизних бо
незрозуміло навіть скільки мобілізованих
хтось оцінює що їх 500 тисяч А хтось
каже що мобілізація закінчилася і та й
інше брехня відверте відповідно чи то
700 тисяч чи той мільйон виїхали але
питання не в тому що вони поїхали якщо
вони виїхали і як і раніше обслуговують
клієнтів Росії то фундаментально для
економіки це впливає тільки на супутній
бізнес на оренду квартири продаж
автомобілів вони зараз наші 65% упали
пропозиція на ринку нерухомості зросла в
тричі експерти
захищають і ще один важливий аспект
мобілізація також вдарила по
внутрішньому попиту в Росії що вплине на
торгівлю в умовах невизначеності росіяни
вважають за краще економити гроші